[音楽]
いや基盤健康栄養研究所の夏目弥生です
コンピューテーショナルバイオロジーと
いう
コンピューターを使って生物学を研究する
分野の研究者です
私たちが取り組んでいる研究の一つに
AIで薬のターゲットを探すというのが
あります
新しい薬を作るときには
病気を分子レベルで理解するということが
必要になります私たちの体は
DNA
RNA
タンパク質など
様々な分子生体分子と呼ばれるもので作ら
れていますまた
色々な細胞が互いに協力しあってその役割
を果たしながら健康な体を保っています
ですがこの生体分子に異常が起きたり
細胞の働きに異常が起きたりすると
病気になります
つまりこの異常が起きた生体分子や
細胞などを
正しい状態
正常な状態に近づけることができれば
病気が治せるのではないかというふうに
考えられますそこでそれが可能になるよう
に
薬の効かせどころというのを探せる主張が
ありますこの薬の効かせどころが
創薬ターゲット
創薬標的と呼ばれるものです
もともとこの
薬の開発というのは時間もお金もとても
かかることです
例えば一つの薬を作るのに
数百億また10年以上もの時間がかかると
言われていますそこでこの薬の開発をどう
にかして
効率よく
開発の負担を軽減したいというような
ニーズがありますそこで人工知能
AIN機体が寄せられています
これまで
薬の形をデザインするなど
様々なAIの開発が進められてきましたが
この
創薬標的を
AIを使って探すという取り組みはまだ
開拓が進んでいないという状況です
ただこの
創薬標的を探すというステップは
薬の開発において非常に重要なステップ
です
まず今の薬の開発において
創薬薬の候補物質が人に効くかどうかを
確かめる段階では
失敗率が約7割とかなり高いのが現状です
これよりも前の段階で
実験動物では
薬として効果があったにも関わらずです
つまり人以外の動物では聞くのに人では
効かないということが起こりうるわけです
そこで私たちは
動物実験で見つかってきた創薬標的を人で
検証するというアプローチではなく人の
データを使って
直接創薬標的を探そうというような試みを
始めました
具体的に人のデータというのはどういった
ものがあるかと言いますとまずは診療情報
ですね
病気になると
病院に行きますけれどもそうすると
いろいろな検査を受けたりですとかお医者
さんからいろいろな質問をされたりといっ
たことがありますけれどもその時の情報を
集めたデータですそれから
薬を作るときには
体の中の異常を生体分子レベルで理解する
ということが
必要になりますので
体の中の異常を検出するために一度に実験
で生体分子を
網羅的に測定するという技術を使って
データ収集を行います
このようなデータをオミックスデータと
呼びます
こうしてデータ収集が終わったら
次はデータ解析ですね
私たちは
診療項目と直接関連のある生体分子の
グループを自動的に探し出すAIの開発を
行いましたつまりある病気の患者さんで
典型的に認められる症状これと
関連のある生体分子を見つけ出すことが
できるようになりましたこの
技術によって
例えば病気の原因やメカニズムがわかって
いないような
難病であっても
データを収集すれば
創薬標的の探索ができる
薬を作るサポートができるのではないかと
期待しています
このように私たちは
診療情報などのデータとAIを活用して
薬の開発がより効率よく進むように日々
研究をしていますが
将来的には
プライバシーの保護などに配慮しつつも今
よりももっと診療情報やおみくじデータと
いったデータが
多くの人を助けるための目的で活用される
ように
臨んでいます
例えば私が何かの病気になったときその
病気に関する情報や体の中で何が起きたの
かといった情報これがいつか他の誰かが
同じ病気になった時にその人を助けるそれ
が実現するように
AIと共に生きる社会を思い描いています